today the Matt wall show Democrats in
the household a hearing on alleged
anti-lgbt violence blaming this made-up
epidemic on hate speech but what is hate
speech and what's so bad about it
nothing as it turns out also the Senate
moves to ban Tick-Tock on government
devices but really it should be banned
on all devices Nationwide so when are we
going to do that a new film starring AOC
earns a staggering ten thousand dollars
in its first week of release across the
entire country plus Nancy Pelosi is
caught on film degrading and
dehumanizing white males but what else
is new all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
hardier on the economy means that
essential practical gifts will be in
high demand this year give the most
essential gift of all America's best
meat and seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family when you give a box of good
ranchers you're giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with 100 American
USDA prime and uppercut Choice choices
of beef Chicken and Seafood other meat
delivery companies and even your local
grocery stores import lower Quality Meat
from overseas don't give your friends
and family less than America's best this
year not sure what to order well good
ranchers now offers gift cards so you
can let your friends and family choose
for themselves what they want or you can
give the gift of a subscription and
inflation proves someone's meat budget
for them go to goodranchers.com use code
Walsh at checkout to get 35 off your
gift that is goodranchers.com code Walsh
for 35 off good ranchers American Meat
delivered
even after the White House was lit up
like the gay pride rainbow and drag
queens were invited for a celebration of
a bill of a bill codifying gay marriage
and effectively abolishing abolishing
religious liberty Nationwide still
Democrats in Washington decided that
they had not done enough LGBT related
virtue signaling this week they've done
quite a lot of it but uh not enough you
can never do enough in their minds
anyway and so yesterday A House of
Representatives oversight committee held
a hearing on the subject of quote
anti-lgbtqi plus violence and extremism
now much of this hearing revolved around
the Colorado gay club shooting an attack
that the media and the left are still
blaming on alleged anti-gay rhetoric
even though no actual motive has been
identified or announced
uh it's in fact it's been several weeks
now since this happened and we've still
been told almost nothing about the guy
who did it was still alive and in police
custody and has been talking to police
but we haven't heard anything about what
he said
which is quite suspicious
but all that of course is unimportant to
the propagandists there were several
notable moments to come out of the
hearing and not all of it had to do with
uh supposed anti-lgbt violence and
extremism for instance one witness a
woman named Jesse pocock with an
activist group called Inside Out took
the opportunity to effectively deny the
existence of D transitioners they don't
exist she said listen
a lot of people in the news coming out
de-transitioning
could you speak to that phenomenon in in
what what's that person going through uh
did they get wrong were they going
through a period is it just a fluid
thing I mean could you speak to that
I can't really speak to an individual
individual personal
experience I mean you know somebody is
gender is just a really personal
experience but I can speak to you I've
been in this work for a long time I know
a lot of trans folks close friends
family members and the concerns
of anyone detransitioning so I honestly
don't think it's a real there's there's
a there's a number of cases in the news
right now uh where this this is
happening in the in the concern for
parents have is you know we've all had
awkward teen years uh where we've
question things in existence and a lot
of things and the question is is is kids
who are maybe making a permanent
decision even without the input of their
parents
now the congressman unfortunately speaks
over her at the end rather than allowing
her to continue to bury herself with her
own insanity but she does say it's a
quote her I've never heard of a case of
anyone detransitioning so I honestly
don't think it's a real thing
now there are only two ways to interpret
that claim the first and most likely
interpretation is that she's simply
lying and knowingly denying the
existence of the transitioners so that
she can continue to trans the kids
without impediment the other possibility
which really isn't any better is that
this woman lives in such an enclosed
sealed off hermetically sealed bubble
that she actually has managed to avoid
ever hearing about any case of any
person regretting the fact that they
mutilated themselves
either way whether she's a god-forsaken
liar or oblivious in the extreme or some
combination she is not a credible voice
on this subject and yet she's been
brought on as an expert witness at a
congressional hearing
somehow though that wasn't the most
disturbing thing that she said during
that exchange she was also asked about
the age of consent for gender
Transitions and this is how she answered
you know we have to do everything we can
to make sure that young person is safe
and protected we have uh we are
constantly filing reports of abuse and
neglect because of parents I understand
the cases of people it sounds like
you're deflecting the question a little
bit uh I understand cases that abuse
there's laws to protect abuse I mean
schools actually are legally obligated
to report cases that abuse same for
churches and and the like anyone who
deals with young people but you know do
parents have a right should they be
informed about what's going on
do they have a right to know what's
going on in their kids lives
so I think again
those of us who are protecting and
supporting Young people are there and
trusted with the information of the
things that they are dealing with in
terms of parents rights to know at
schools I mean here in Colorado parents
don't have the right if a young person
is questioning their gender or their
sexuality there are laws in place that
say that they have the right to process
that with their trusted counselor so you
do and so forth you do a significant
amount of your work with kids even
starting at age 13. yeah what what would
be the age of consent then in your in
your mind
uh in our community the age of consent
to mental health therapy is 12 years old
so we have laws that enable young people
to connect with trusted adults who can
support them that is just so important
it prevents suicide and so we serve
young people at 13 because we know they
come to us and we can prevent negative
Health outcomes for them
this is just so frustrating to watch and
not even only because of the crazy
nonsense she's spewing there but because
her questioner bails her out time and
time again bells are out by cutting her
off at the beginning of that clip she
says that she has filed numerous reports
of abuse and neglect against parents who
don't accept their child's trans
identity
I'd like to hear more about that what
does that mean
so if uh if a what an eight-year-old boy
says uh Daddy I'm a girl and is not
immediately affirmed as such
you're going to file an abuse and
neglect claim with CPS over that
that doesn't surprise me I know that
they're doing that kind of thing let's
talk about that
instead he just moves on from that and
in fact even agrees with it says well we
know that abuse and neglect of course is
bad
though what she says later is just as
shocking parents she says don't have the
right to know about their child's gender
transition and that the transition can
begin at 12 which is according to her
the age of consent now she says it's the
age of consent for mental health therapy
but what she's really talking about when
she's says mental health therapy is the
uh is you know the uh the the
indoctrination
of a child into their trans identity
they are able to consent to begin that
process at the age of 12.
but this is a direction that the
Democrats didn't want the hearing to go
what they wanted to focus on instead is
all the dangerous rhetoric and hate
speech which is giving rise to this
purported epidemic of anti-lgbt violence
and to that end a trans activist named
Olivia hunt
tried to explain how words like groomer
are contributing to this supposed
problem
people who are already receptive to that
message take it to heart and it
reinforces their prejudices in their
minds trans people either become victims
to be saved from ourselves or villains
to be punished
one example of this in action is the
misuse of the term groomer anti-lgbtq
activists have appropriated this
terminology used by survivors of
childhood sexual abuse and used it to
slander lgbtq people and our allies as
predatory harmful toward children in
reality trans people are significantly
more likely to be the victims of sexual
abuse than perpetrators of it and now
this misuse determinology has become
part of the political discourse around
trans people and is invoked as a reason
to further restrict our rights in the
name of protecting children
this same rhetoric has subsequently been
used as justification for violent
anti-lgbtq activism heavily armed
protesters have made numerous attacks or
attempts at intimidation against
family-friendly Pride events and drag
performances around the country even
hospitals have been targeted with bomb
threats and intimidation tactics based
on social media figures spreading
baseless Stories the providers are in
their words mutilating children
there's a straight line that can be
drawn from the legislation trying to
strip trans people of our human rights
to the increasingly hostile and
inflammatory rhetoric portraying us as a
threat to society to the acts of
violence that have taken far too many
lives
okay so a few quick points here first of
all it's true that many trans people
have a history of being sexually abused
um that's true now if the psychiatric
industry in this country had any moral
courage or intellectual curiosity uh
they might be investigating why exactly
people who have experienced sexual
trauma
are more likely to try and disassociate
themselves from their own gender and
claim a new identity
might there be some sort of connection
there that's worth exploring
well we don't explore it's just
something we're not even supposed to
talk about
second
um it's it's not in our words that
hospitals are mutilating children they
are in fact chopping the breasts off of
biners they are in fact prescribing
drugs that chemically castrate and
sterilize kids the word mutilate means
according to the dictionary until they
change it to inflict serious damage on
that's what it means
all of these things constitute damage
and the damage is both physical and
serious so when we use the term mutilate
we are using it because it is the most
accurate way to describe what is going
on and third we hear again how rhetoric
causes violence and this was of course
the main theme throughout the hearing
and as one witness put it hate starts
with speech
hate rhetoric from politicians religious
leaders and media Outlets is that the
root of the attacks like at Club cute
and it needs to stop now rhetoric that
makes people less than for being
different rhetoric that threatens to
silence what sports we can play what
bathrooms we can use how we Define our
family and who I can marry
every American
every American especially those elected
to positions of power has the
responsibility and a choice to use their
words consciously
hate starts with speech
it starts with speech now this was also
the thesis of a Scientific American
report published this week titled how
anti-lgbtq plus rhetoric fuels violence
and it warns that hate speech from the
far right is increasing the risk of
violence against lgbtq plus people such
as the club Q shooting now the report
then of course as always specifically
singles out myself lives of tick tock
Tucker Carlson the three foremost
Peddlers of hate speech in the country
we're told and it asserts that we have
sparked an increasing epidemic of
anti-lgbt violence now I say asserts
because there is nothing like proof or
evidence provided whether in the
Scientific American report or in this
hearing or any other time they talk
about this
there's certainly no evidence that we
have inspired violence much less called
for but there's also no evidence that
the epidemic of anti-lgbt violence is
even occurring in the first place
outside of the Club Q shooting an event
that once again we still do not have a
confirmed motive for
they don't give very many specific
examples of actual acts of violence
carried out against gay or trans people
a picture is painted of a country where
LGBT people are being constantly
assaulted and killed by right-wing
bigots and yet the picture is quite
fuzzy and there's not a lot of detail to
it
that's because it is largely imaginary
they have invented this crisis they've
invented it which means that they can
invent the cause too
and the cause is me lives of tick tock
Tucker you all of us who Express views
on gender and sexuality that that uh
that they disagree with uh we are guilty
because we are peddling hate speech
and that brings me to the Crux of the
matter here what what is hate speech
exactly well hate speech is any speech
that the left hates and it really is
that simple
if you don't believe me
then go up to any leftist
and and really test me on this go up to
any other leftist ask them if there is
any criticism of gender ideology or the
LGBT agenda
that they would not consider hate speech
is there any way to for example object
to the transitioning of minors without
engaging in hate speech
is there no I know I get blamed for
being very abrasive and direct and blunt
and uh you know inflammatory in the way
that I phrase things fine whatever is
there any way that I could phrase it
that would be acceptable or at least not
hate speech
is there any way to advocate for
biblical marriage without engaging name
speech is there any way to defend the
biological nature of Womanhood without
being guilty of hate speech have they
ever in their lives heard anyone ever
express any of these views in a way that
they did not consider hate speech
the answer on all counts will be no
and I dare any of them to prove me wrong
I dare any of them to provide an example
of a fundamental criticism of their view
on gender and sexuality that they do not
classify as hate speech
they can't
and that's because hate speech simply is
by definition the rejection of left-wing
ideas that's what hate speech is
and to be clear when I say that okay
it's not that the left has misused or
abused the term hate speech to support
their causes that's not it they invented
the term this is their term it exists
for no other reason than to silence
conservatives that's the whole point of
the concept
there is no neutral or non-ideological
or non-political way to understand the
concept of hate speech the concept is
nonsense when considered objectively if
you try to use remove ideology and
politics from it and just think about it
on its own terms I mean hate speech the
hell is that so speech that expresses
hate is hate speech
but how could you just lump all that
into a category and say well oh that's
bad aren't there things that are worthy
of hate don't we all agree that there
are some things in life that we all
should hate if I use my speech to
communicate
my hatred of uh slavery or rape is that
then hate speech well in a literal sense
yes I'm using speech I'm saying that I
hate something it's hate speech
but that's not what they mean because
hate speech is again speech they hate I
think we might better call it hated
speech so when you hear hate speech
think hated speech
and that's why I don't bother defending
myself
against the hate speech charge
there are some on the right
who do and who waste a lot of breath by
saying I don't engage in hate speech you
engage in hate speech you're the hate
speecher not me
I embrace it so when they say uh this
hate speech Matt sure okay
yes I say things the left hates and yes
I myself Express hatred
I hate the abuse of children I hate the
assault on truth and science I hate the
left's attack on Common Sense and
reality and decency
um I hate the trans agenda
hate it
with a passion
hate all of that
and I use speech to express that hatred
and it is speech to the left hates so
the speech is hateful and hated
hatred all around hate speech sure fine
guilty as charged
and proud of it
let's get to five headlines
a recent data breach has left 5.4
million Twitter users exposed to
potential phishing attacks and identity
theft is just one example of how cyber
criminals can easily access your
personal information you need to make
sure you're protecting your identity
with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock
detection alerts you to potential
identity threats you may not spot on
your own like loans taken out in your
name or crimes committed by thieves
pretending to be you if you do become a
victim of identity threat threat a uh a
dedicated U.S based restoration
specialist will work to fix it nobody
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it's easy to help protect
yourself with LifeLock by Norton join
now and save 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com Walsh that's lifelock.com
Walsh for 25 percent off
so the daily wire has this report the
Senate unanimously passed a bill that
would ban the use of tick tock on
government devices amid growing National
Security concerns over the chinese-owned
social media platform the no tick tock
on government devices act introduced by
Senator Josh Hawley was passed late on
Wednesday it says Tick Tock is a trojan
horse for the Chinese Communist party
it's a major security risk the United
States and until it's forced to
severtise the China completely has no
place on government devices highly said
in a statement States across the U.S are
Banning Tick-Tock and government devices
time for Joe Biden and Democrats to help
do the same the bill will need to be
passed in the house and signed by
President Joe Biden to become law
and this is only uh just one bill
related to tick tock a group of
bipartisan lawmakers is also leading a
drive to completely ban the use of
tick-tock Nationwide for everyone
Senator Marco Rubio introduced the
legislation in the Senate this month
Representatives Mike Gallagher and Raja
Krishna morthy let's say introduced
companion legislation in the house the
bipartisan anti-social CCP Act is a
strong act a step in protecting our
nation from the nefarious digital
surveillance and influence operations of
totalitarian regimes and Marco Rubio was
on Tucker Carlson last night talking
about this build a ban Tick Tock
Nationwide
uh so a few things first of all the the
great thing
and of course it should be to begin with
banned on government devices
um
even if it wasn't a a communist Chinese
surveillance operation which it is we
should still ban it on government it's a
government device why should you have
any kind of social media ban all social
media on government devices let's do
that
and the really great thing about banning
tick tock on government devices is that
it will prevent gen Z from getting jobs
in government they're not going to want
to work in government if they can't have
Tick Tock at the ready so I consider
that a benefit
but of course it should obviously go
beyond that and it should be banned
Nationwide there's just there's no
arguments I have not heard one
Salient argument as to why Tick Tock
should not be banned
Nationwide across the entire country
I haven't heard it and yet it remains
unbanned yet it's it's still out there
and you're we're allowed to use it when
there's no good argument for it
it is once again just a fact that it's a
surveillance operation by the communist
communist Chinese government that's what
it is that's how it's used
they're using it to
spy on us to get access to our data to
our information get access to our phones
that's how it's being used
and on top of that as if we need more
reason to get rid of it uh on top of
that it's it's just absolutely toxic for
kids
it is uh it's destroying kids and it's
not the only social media platform of
course if you get rid of wanna just be
replaced by another we understand that
that's not a good enough reason to keep
it around
so you've got something that's
that's poisonous to kids
that's just like ruining entire
generations of kids who are addicted to
this thing
um and also it's being used by an
adversarial government to spy on us
and yet we're still sitting around
talking about hmm should we
is it really the right thing to ban it
though
um all right let's move to this so if
hate speech makes no sense neither does
the category of hate crime
um
and also at the aforementioned hearing
there was another Witness
who much of what he says here unlike
some of the other Witnesses of this
hearing who just were
everything they said was totally insane
much of what he says here I agree with
and he calls for the for the death
penalty for hate crimes let's listen
population level most people who hate
will never convert their hate into a
crime meaning the education produces
little prevention for hour a dollar
expended
rather the members of this committee
want to more effectively combat hate
crime they should do so by supporting
the criminal justice system
increased funding for police hiring to
remediate the decline in police
employment per capita since the Great
Recession
better front police investigations
integral to clearing hate crime cases
supports state and local prosecutors
informing specialized hate crime bureaus
including by coordinating information
sharing in the challenging area of hate
crime prosecution
increase Federal hate crime penalties
and encourage the Department of Justice
to pursue hate crime charges in states
where local laws are insufficient such
as in New York state Where the Buffalo
grocery shooter cannot be executed for
his defense a situation in our lab which
also obtains in Colorado
hate crime against lgbtq people and
otherwise is a serious issue and we must
take it seriously
doing that means treating hate criminals
like the criminals they are and bringing
the full power of the justice system to
bear on them
now I agree that these Mass Shooters
should be executed absolutely execute
them execute them do it swiftly do it
publicly as far as I am concerned bring
back public executions uh I've long
advocated for that
um for mass shootings and for many other
crimes as well
but the issue is with the category of
hate crime as we've talked about on the
show recently is there any motivation
for a mass shooting
that would be less bad
than any other motivation
okay is there a less bad version of a
mass shooting
now I'm not sure that I believe as some
will say that all such crimes are
motivated by hatred because that's one
criticism of the hate crime category is
that well if you're killing people then
obviously you hate them so how can we
even distinguish I don't think I agree
with that I think I think that crimes
can be motivated by other things
indifference to human life Envy uh you
know a kind of Psychopathic boredom I
mean these people are motivated by all
sorts of things hard to know exactly
what's going on in the mind of a mass
murderer whatever's going on in there
it's dark and twisted and horrifying
but why does it matter I mean
imagine you have two mass shootings okay
imagine two my shootings on the same day
in the same town killing the same number
of people okay hypothetically and
in one case the mass shooter is a racist
and we know that because he's got the
manifesto and everything and he's
targeting black people and he's very
open about that's why he's doing it
in the other case the mass shooter is
let's say a psychopathic nihilist
indifferent to human life
um killing people of all different races
and doing it just for entertainment and
to feel a sense of power and control in
his life
same number of dead people
same trauma for the survivors uh same
bloodshed
is the former crime really worse than
the latter
really it's worse
I mean how how can it be worse how can
either be worse than the other there's
it's as bad as you could possibly get
um should one be treated harsher like
are you gonna walk in onto the scene of
the second shooting and go oh my God
what happened here this is why did he do
this and someone says well he's a
nihilist a psychopath he's indifferent
to human life oh oh so he's it this
wasn't hate well phew thank God I
thought you had a bad reason to murder
32 people
in fact if anything if anything
it goes the other way if anything we
should be slightly less worried about
the hate crime perpetrator
because hatred
can be redeemed a hateful person can be
in theory reformed now mass murderer
should all still be executed in my
opinion
but my point is simply that of the two
types of violent scumbags the hate crime
bigot and the nihilistic psychopath
um if we have to parse this and and
split hairs and everything and who's
worse than the other
the latter probably poses the greater
danger and is less likely to be reformed
I think I think you could make a a
better argument for that
but though again to my mind they should
be treated the same because this whole
argument is you know maybe it's
interesting on an academic level but
when you try to put it into action the
criminal justice system it's just
absolutely ridiculous
because no matter why they did it it
doesn't matter it's just as bad no
matter what the reason was
all right the Daily Mail has this
reported documentary by Nancy Pelosi's
daughter Alexandra
reveals that the house Speaker uh was
speaking to President Barack Obama after
Democrats endured the famous off-year
shellacking and this is back in 2010
blaming white male voters getting in a
mood over the sour economy her
assessment came after a wipe out the
cost of the party its majority after
enactment of Obama's signature
Affordable Care Act
then often to write it as Obamacare by
its opponents so this documentary is
apparently called Pelosi in the house
and if you want to watch here for some
reason it's on HBO so you can go if you
want to watch a documentary about Nancy
Pelosi you can go do that but here's the
scene in question
are worried about the economics
and our members have said they don't
regret their health care bill got across
the board even if we never test Health
Care reform we were still going to lose
this election because of 9 10
unemployment because it wasn't about
that it was about jobs
the white male thing was just that's a
dominant thing and when they're going to
have a job at the net Food and I'm going
so I would not have to make some
decisions in our problems about how we
go forward
the white male thing she says the white
the white male thing that's just when
they don't have a job they get in a mood
now needless to say uh this is a career
killer even for someone like Nancy
Pelosi if you put any other group in
that sentence
imagine you're saying you know the black
male thing really get in a mood
sometimes
she says that and it's done she's all
it's over like this is someone who's
been
in the House of Representatives for for
350 years before it even existed she was
she was in it uh and that would be
enough to kill her grip but you could
say that about white males
and the thing is you know they put this
in a documentary it's not like this was
some behind the scenes footage that she
did
her this is her daughter put this out
there this wasn't some kind of expose
they have no problem with this she would
say this publicly the Democrats would
say she would say almost exactly that in
front of a microphone at a press
conference she has no problem with that
because there's there's no penalty there
is no
um
you know there's no downside really
politically
do heaping scorn and contempt on white
males the white male thing
she's calling us things just to be clear
so why not they're very open about it
and one of the reasons why they can be
so open about it
and why there is no penalty
is that Republicans
don't have the guts or the brains to
counter this
no they she can go out and say whatever
she wants about white males
because even her political opponents
won't say anything about it they're not
going to stand up there and say this she
she is she is she has hatred of white
males she is she is anti-white male okay
she's a racist and a sexist they're not
going to get up and say that
they're not going to accuse her
specifically by name of anti-white male
bigotry they won't say it
even though that's exactly what we just
heard
and Democrats could not be more clear
about it
in villainizing and demonizing white
males
they're very open but Republicans of
course the media is not going to call
her on it so if the media is not going
to call her on it and her political
opponents won't call her on it then
that's it she's fine
and Republicans won't do that they will
not by name they will not name
anti-white racism and they will not name
anti-special especially anti-white male
bigotry
they won't do it
to their own detriment
because you know they're afraid that if
they do they're afraid they get up there
and they say and they say what we just
heard
is is dehumanizing and bigoted against
white males
you know white males they are a group of
of Americans in this country they
deserve to be defended they don't
deserve to be treated this way
the Republicans are afraid that if they
say that that it's going to upset all
the other groups that they're trying to
win
they're worried that it's going to
alienate the black vote if they speak up
for white males
which by the way like even if it did
from a political perspective
you know as a Republican
it's like you're only going to win
you're only going to win a very small
portion of the black vote anyway so even
if it's true that it made your numbers
go from three percent to two percent
politically who cares
because the white male vote politically
is more important to you because they're
they're voting for you in greater
numbers
but
more to the point it's not true that
it's going to alienate other groups
now far left activists of course if you
speak up for white males they're going
to accuse you of well you're saying that
you you're saying you don't hate white
males well that must mean that you do
hate black people
yeah far left activists are going to
play that game but they're not going to
vote for you anyway it gives a damn what
they say
normal people aren't going to interpret
it that way
a normal black person a normal woman
a normal person any racial minority they
hear you speaking up in defense of white
males especially when they're being
degraded and dehumanized in that way
normal people in those groups they're
not gonna they're not offended by that
of course they're not
so you're not offending normal people
but you could actually be motivating
White
males
which is an important voting Block it's
a voting block that you need
if you don't have them you don't win
and that is also a voting block that is
that has been uh demoralized and
disenfranchised
you know this is one of the things that
after 2020
um we we never talked about you know
because we talked about a lot of things
with the election
we never actually talked about the fact
that you know Trump lost white males he
didn't lose them he lost the person that
white males were less invested in that
election than they have been in 2016.
the numbers went down
we never had that conversation
um which maybe we should
so maybe maybe that's a group of people
like politicians specifically speak up
in defense of every other group by name
they'll speak up for black Americans
they'll speak up for women they'll speak
up for Asians they'll speak up for every
group
but they will not speak up for white
males by name
and it turns out that does have an
effect
because when you've got a group of
Voters who feel like you don't give a
crap about them that you won't even sit
you won't even acknowledge them by name
they're less motivated to vote for you
doesn't mean they're going to vote in
Democrat just means that they're going
to stay home they're not motivated
they don't feel represented
all right
that's what we got here
uh speak okay well speaking of
documentaries since we're on the subject
maybe we should uh mention this too this
from the daily wire
the climate may be getting hot but aoc's
new movie is most definitely not well
done representative Alexandria Casa
Cortez has a new documentary out to the
end
um and if movie theaters are paying
attention to ticket sales they realize
it's already run to the end they flick
opened on December 9th at 120 theaters
but since then it's made nine thousand
six hundred and sixty seven dollars okay
you know it's about a week
on over 100 screens it's made less than
ten thousand dollars that is 80 bucks a
screen
and let's say the tickets are 16 25 as
they are Regal theaters that would
equate to fewer than 600 people who
actually saw it so that's about uh do
the math on that so that's like um
just about five people five or six
people a theater went to go see this
movie
perhaps viewers just didn't want to sit
through this this is uh the movie
synopsis it's stopping the climate
crisis is a question of political
courage and the clock is ticking over
three years of turbulence and crisis
four young women fight for a green New
Deal and ignite a historic shift in U.S
climate politics now the film Drew 83
approval from Rotten Tomatoes of course
but
nobody actually wants to see this thing
and I know that you're really hoping
that you'll get a chance to watch the
trailer of this because you're hearing
the description you're thinking I need
to see some clips of this thing and
don't worry I got you covered uh here's
the trailer
fighting for change politically requires
faith
we are building an army of young people
to stop the climate crisis and create
millions of good jobs for Our Generation
everyone wants to talk about this
dispassionately but this is a world that
I'll raise my kids in
the more Centrist Wing is arguing that
they want to maintain the status quo
ain't nobody gonna keep us down this is
going to be the moonshot of Our
Generation
moments of Crisis crack open the window
of possibility
sometimes I feel like my job is to get
my hands dirty you're not going to trick
us hell no
now is the time to leverage our power we
have tens of thousands of new people
joining
we're in the battle for the soul of the
democratic party make them feel like
they're going to lose their seats if
they don't support this let's stop let's
stop watching it so you've seen of it
um
a few things first
it it comes interesting things going on
here I mean nothing interesting in the
film itself but um first the Democrat
Party
just doesn't have any stars at all they
don't they don't have any interesting
people
in the Democrat Party
um AOC is the closest
and yet you know she's she's probably
the biggest star
in the Democrat Party she's not the one
that has the most influence in
Washington
for sure but but she's the biggest star
uh most well-known most famous popular I
guess
and yet and yet still like she's the
best they can do as far as that goes and
and yet nobody cares because she's
actually not interesting at all
it's not an interesting person
part of the problem is that in order to
be interesting you have to have some
rough edges you know you need to have
some aspects of yourself that aren't
politically correct
that's what makes someone interesting
um but when you perfectly fit yourself
into this politically correct box it may
prevent you from getting backlash it may
make you above criticism in the
mainstream fine but just like it's not
interesting
and also the left once again as we see
they find it difficult to make films
that preach their message in an
appealing and entertaining way they
didn't always have this difficulty
because the left has been the Hollywood
has been left leaning for decades and
they've been putting out
films that you know propagandize
um
in their Direction and they've been
doing that for decades but they used to
be able to do it in a way that people
found found interesting and found
entertaining and wanted to go watch the
movies
they're not as able to do that anymore
part of that is like we always talk
about it's the kind of Christian film
phenomenon where they do the same thing
in the reverse with Christian films do
they put them they put the message up
before anything so they go message first
they worry about getting the message
across before they worry about actually
putting out an entertaining piece of
content
that's part of it I think also
you know
they don't think that the masses are
worthy of being appealed to in the first
place I think
they think almost like they would be
it'd be beneath them
to try to appeal to the masses
because they have contempt for that they
have too much contempt for the masses at
this point
to actually try to connect with them I
think that's part of the issue all right
finally
this is from the mirror it says science
fiction is about to match up with
reality as the world's first artificial
womb facility has been announced
where you'll be able to choose your
baby's characteristics from a menu Ecto
life the brainchild of berlin-based
Hashem
a biotechnologist and science
Communicator is a concept based on over
50 years of groundbreaking scientific
research in theory they'll be able to
grow thirty thousand babies a year in
their lab and he believes the facilities
would allow infertile couples to
conceive a baby and become the true
biological parents of their own
offspring but they also plan to offer an
elite package that would allow you to
genetically engineer the embryo before
implanting it into the artificial womb
with everything from eye and hair color
to strength height and intelligence as
choices
Hashem explains introducing Ecto life
the world's first artificial womb
facility which is powered entirely by
renewable energy according to the World
Health Organization around 300 000 women
die from pregnancy complications Ecto
life artificial womb is designed to
alleviate human suffering and reduce the
chances of C-sections
with Ecto life premature birth and
C-sections will be a thing of the past
and so they want to farm all this out
rather than doing it the old-fashioned
way of having you know women
um gestating the children in their womb
we don't need to do that anymore because
they'll have artificial wombs so you
make the baby
you know it's like it's
baking a cake or something you mix all
the ingredients together pop it in the
oven you can go live your life while
they grow the baby in the artificial
womb
you know I'm skeptical about whether
this technology will ever actually be
functional
um
or if it will just continue to exist in
theory they've been talking about doing
things like this for decades
um and maybe they're closer now than
they've ever been but I'm I'm skeptical
of that
either way
I will never fail to appreciate the
irony that we are as a culture obsessed
with Organic
all-natural
you know we're obsessed with that when
it comes to
items you find at the grocery store
we're obsessed with finding things that
are not genetically engineered
unless we're talking about human beings
themselves
right as our food gets more organic our
manner of human reproduction on the
other hand becomes less organic
so we can see the value of doing things
organically when it comes to food when
it comes to Cosmetics whatever
but somehow the very same people who see
the value there they can't see it when
it comes to themselves and reproduction
and I mean eventually our salads will be
more organic than the people eating them
that's that's where we're headed
and I think many people on the left in
particular can't see a problem with this
because
they don't have any concept of of of
human dignity to begin with
they just have no concept of that
and so for those of us who have a
concept of human dignity even if we
struggle to articulate
what human dignity is or why it's
important
um because it's
something that
you know for
most of human history it was it was not
something that was fundamentally
challenged
but now it is like when you have people
that are there that are just flat out
denying that human that that human
dignity exists in the first place
and so but those of us who innately
recognize it
um
it can be it can be hard for us to
understand
is and and we see something like this
and we just because we innately
recognize the value of human dignity we
see something like this and we
immediately see it as horrifying like of
course
you know grow babies in a artificial
womb and pick out what kind of people
they're gonna be from a menu and just
like constructing them like frankincense
it's horrifying
we instinctively recognize that
but people on the left they don't
because they don't see human dignity as
a as a thing and you know human dignity
is rooted in the fact that we are made
in the image and likeness of God
that's what's rooted in
but if you believe as people on the left
do that
there is no God and that we are gods
ourselves
man that makes kind of sense so you you
know we are Gods there is no God except
the individual
and so I can make a person in my image
because I'm the god
I think that's what's happening here
let's get to the comment section
you know women love getting new pajamas
at Christmas time that's one thing I
know for sure Pajamagram makes it really
easy for us man this year I'm getting my
wife a set of pajamas from their
naturally nude line the texture and feel
of these pajamas is so silky and smooth
that I know she'll love them if you have
no idea what to get your girlfriend or
wife this year trust me she wants these
pajamas but you need to order today
because last year they sold out before
Christmas order today and Pajamagram
Graham will uh Pajamagram will include a
free matching naturally nude nightie
with your order that's 75 of savings on
their best selling selling uh holiday
gift Pajamagram offers free gift
packaging so you can give your gifts and
put them under the tree and it's all
ready to go so go to pajamagram.com
right now order the naturally nude
pajamas that's pajamagram.com for
naturally nude pajamas don't forget to
tell them Matt sent you
Laura says I'm alarmed that the
Christian group was denied service but
at least they didn't give their good
hard-earned money to those haters I live
in Brooklyn and one time several years
back I overheard two 20-somethings
saying that they didn't and wouldn't
patronize a certain very popular Diner
because they found out that the owner
donated to pro-life organizations
this is something that's happening more
and more in fact uh I didn't even know
about this we it was uh revealed on
Backstage last night our Christmas
backstage episode if you watched it that
uh this happened now I didn't we had our
Christmas party a couple days ago
and I didn't go because you know my
wife's very pregnant and she didn't want
to go she wasn't feeling very well
I could have still gone by myself but
parties are bad enough if I'm gonna go
to one I need my wife there she's my
she's my pinch hitter she's like she's
the one who does all the talking so I
can't so I couldn't go if she wasn't
going so I stayed home and uh so I I
found out it's after the fact but
apparently there was
um you know a nearby restaurant where
some members of The Daily wire were
going to go trying to reserve a table
and
were told by someone at the restaurant
that essentially they're not welcome
because they pose a
I think the phrase was something like a
danger to the staff you know you're
dangerous people
so
it seems to be happening with increasing
regularity
that people whether because Christian or
conservative
being denied certainly in this case
they'd already made the reservation
put down a deposit on it
told you're not welcome here
so there there are cases of that
happening in fact in our case very close
to home
I'm not aware of any case anywhere in
the country
of something similar happening on the
left side or to the left side
of a Christian or conservative business
owner saying to
a group of people you know to gay people
we're not going to serve you because
you're gay or even going up to left-wing
activists and saying well because of
your ideological convictions I can in
good conscious serve you I haven't heard
of any case like that
all right
let's see
Jerry Lancaster says how can Media
Matters watch Matt every day
and not become fans
I I ask myself
that same question uh Jenna says what is
your take on Knowles's tweet that he
feels sorry for Sam Britton
well
he's a nice guy I mean he's based don't
get me wrong a dangerous right-wing
extremist of course not even welcome in
restaurants
but he's nice also
and I'm I'm not as nice I have to say
that I don't feel sorry for for Britain
I understand the point and I've heard
this from other people too that he's a
he's a
he's kind of he's a pathetic figure and
and he is he's mentally deranged and he
lives in a culture that encourages and
foments that derangement rather than
helping him deal with it and so he has
he is a a pathetic pitiful strange freak
of a person
and so it makes sense to pity him you
know it does and I get that
perfectly justifiable way of looking at
this
but I don't
um because I I actually don't think that
a guy like Britain is crazy
that's a it's a reasonable theory that
he's just mentally deranged and crazy
I don't think I think I think he's a
he's a deviant
and deviance is well deviance is deviant
but it's not the same thing as being
delusionally insane right it's not the
same thing as being psychotic
it's not immoral to be insane you can't
it's it's not a it's not a moral judge
if somebody's actually insane we're not
going to pass a moral judgment on them
for being insane
it's not their fault
um it is immoral it is a moral choice to
indulge your deviance
the way that Sam Britton has on the
other hand
so what I see rather is just a totally
narcissistic guy who's chosen to act
this way
and he wants to act out his fetishes in
public and he doesn't care how it makes
anybody else feel how uncomfortable it
makes them
he feels he's totally entitled to do
whatever he wants that's what stealing a
luggage is all about just someone who
totally consumed by their own sense of
entitlement
and so I have a lot
a much harder time pitying someone in
that in that case I think
I think um
and finally Joe says Matt a month later
do you think it was a good idea for
Trump to announce early
announces as I can this early
yeah we talked about this at the time
when he announced his candidacy a month
ago and and I said it's definitely a
risk because I understand the thought
process the thought process is get out
in front
try to crowd out the field before anyone
else jumps in uh also change the subject
from the the midterm so that makes sense
I understand the logic behind it
but the risk is that you get in so early
and now you've announced and now you're
in your campaign mode because you've
announced your campaign and now you've
got to keep the momentum going
for like two years that's that's a long
time to have to try to draw that
momentum out and you also don't have any
other candidates in the field yet so
there's no one to be to attack there's
no one to
um to be debating
so you've got a totally on your own
generate this excitement of momentum and
keep it going
the worst thing you could do is announce
your candidacy and then just sort of
disappear
and all the momentum dies
and it seems like that's more of what
has happened so far and it was kind of
doomed to happen though it's just not
possible even Trump it's just like how
do you keep the momentum going that long
so I think uh
in the end it seems to me to have been a
miscalculation but
um
in effect what it means is that he's
going to have to sort of relaunch his
campaign at a later date he's already
announced it but then you're gonna have
to kind of once we get closer to it it
gets to a point where you can actually
maintain the momentum then sort of
relaunch it
I think that's what he's gonna have to
do
have you been procrastinating your
holiday shopping until the last minute
well I'm here to tell you that uh the
last minute is closer than you think
today is your last chance to guarantee
that your sweet baby gang swag Shack
items arrive before Christmas you got to
get it now get my best-selling LGBT
children's book uh Johnny The Walrus
it's cuddly plush walrus companion you
can indulge in the Nostalgia of the
sweet baby album tea and find the
epitome of the SBG with the Matt Walsh
superfan bundle and for the sweet baby
ladies in the audience who are
struggling to find a gift for the man
the man who aren't in sweet baby gang
don't forget to check out Jeremy's New
Hair Skin and Body Care gift bundles
that are 100 woke free and now 30 off if
they're in the sweet baby and they can
get that too I don't know why we're
delineating that way men need soap and
shampoo but they don't enjoy buying it
for themselves and they especially don't
enjoy buying it from woke corporations
who hate them and their values be it the
luxurious Jeremy's beard kit the tea
tree and peppermint shampoo and
conditioner or my personal favorite
bamboo charcoal body wash made from the
primary food source of my least favorite
animal pandas we're starving more pandas
by the day buy them all up now today is
the last day to order and receive in
time for Christmas so don't
procrastinate any longer go to
jeremy'srazors.com get 30 off your
Jeremy's gift bundles today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
foreign
guilt is a Scourge in this country and a
problem we often talk about on the show
a video that recently went viral from
Tick Tock seems to have captured this
phenomenon perhaps better than anything
else we've seen uh here it is
you know what while we're on the topic
of how white people are just [ __ ] the
world up for everyone
you're not one of the good white people
there are no good white people there are
only anti-racist white people and racist
white people anti-racism is a lifelong
project and the end goal is not for you
to be good it's for society to be good
decenter yourself
do the work it's hard you're going to
get it wrong but if you are not out
there every day actively trying to
understand
you're not a good white person stop
patting yourself on the back stop
congratulating each other stop
separating us from the bad white people
don't sit out there in comments and say
we don't claim them we are them we are
them
we are the ones shooting up schools we
are the ones raping people
we are the ones enslaving people we are
we're them
well speak for yourself lady I have in
fact never done any of those things and
uh of the people who have done them they
are not exclusively white not even close
in fact when it comes to mass shootings
and violent crime in particular white
people are underrepresented as a group
in that category as for slavery
forms of the practice do still exist in
the world but they are happening in
parts of the world with names like India
and Africa and Southeast Asia
um these are not predominantly white
areas of the globe just to be clear but
I'm not really interested in fact
checking this poor unfortunate um I'm
assuming quite lonely white guilt
plagued woman this this actually is
someone that I feel sorry for
um
needless to say you know she has no
notion of what actually happens in the
world much less what has happened in the
world her grasp on History being even
more precarious than her understanding
of current events this is a person like
so many others in our culture who exists
in a bubble and the atmosphere inside
that bubble is comprised almost entirely
of self-loathing and narcissism
it is a volatile often quite confusing
mix and that's why I'd really like to
use this lady as a as a case study and
conduct something of a psychological
evaluation of the white guilt Brigade
every member of the Brigade is an
individual brought to this sorry State
through their own relatively unique set
of circumstances yet there are some
obvious through lines here some things
they all seem to have in common
and we can see many of those things
manifested in this video so let's go
through this uh Point by point three
points particular first
white Guild can either be performative
or sincere and sometimes perhaps usually
a mix of the two the fully performative
variety is usually found among the white
people who have gotten into the race
hustling business and who are profiting
immensely off of it they're the ones who
are writing the books they're the ones
who are giving Dei seminars and so on
and for them this is a scam you know
it's a it's a kind of a
Ponzi scheme it's a business opportunity
they're like the televangelists and the
private jets they've found a way to
profit off of a belief system that they
probably don't subscribe to themselves
but the disciples really do believe it
to some extent at least this woman I'm
going to assume is not making millions
selling anti-racism books or posting
anti-racism seminars she's the person
buying the books and attending the
seminars
she's spending money on the racket not
making it
that's because as you can tell just from
that one minute clip she really does buy
into this nonsense she actually does
hate herself
and that's the point the anti-racism
snake oil salesman
are exploiting the self-loathing of
people like this
she was already lonely she already had a
low self-image she already hated herself
before she ever discovered anti-racism
or learned the vapid meaningless mantras
like do the work
anti-racism simply gave her a way of
understanding her own self-loathing it
gave her something to channel it into
and through
so what she gets out of the deal is if
not Financial profit at least um and if
not emotional stability or happiness at
least she gets a feeling of unearned
moral superiority
she hates herself that much is clear but
she also gets to feel Superior to other
white people who have not done the work
as much as she has
this is exactly the attitude that she's
ranting against in the video but she is
lecturing other white people for their
feelings of superiority while herself
standing on a perch of moral superiority
this is ultimately the promise of
anti-racism
this is the reward that it offers to
White disciples
it will not make you feel better about
yourself it will not give you happiness
but it will at least make you feel
holier than those other white scumbags
second
it's interesting to note
how white women in particular seem to be
so susceptible to this stuff
most of these sorts of videos and I've
seen too many of them are made by women
and if you if you talk to anyone who's
ever been to an anti-racism seminar
um they will tell you that it's usually
a majority women
and I think that's because most
obviously women tend to be more
emotional which is which is a good thing
generally you know a man might sometimes
complain about the overly emotional
women in his life but the truth is that
he wouldn't want it any other way his
wife or girlfriend's emotional Outburst
might annoy him sometimes but he
certainly would rather she be emotional
than cold and distant this is the nature
of the two Sexes right the things that
frustrate us about each other the most
are the things that we love about each
other the most but a woman's more
emotional nature can make her easier to
emotionally manipulate in this way and
in particular women are more naturally
empathetic than men
now this again is a positive trait it's
something that men love about women
yet that empathy if not properly
calibrated and pointed in the right
direction can be exploited and
weaponized and turned against itself
white guilt is in in part a sort of
misplaced mangled perverse deranged form
of empathy
it's not entirely unlike you know the
psychology that leads some women to
strike up love affairs with murderers in
prison
kind of a similar thing going on
third
final point
whether it's a man or a woman expressing
their anti-racist white guilt what we're
also seeing is the religious impulse at
work
this may be the most important point to
understand there is there is uh no
escaping the fact that man that man is
religious by Nature we naturally search
for the Transcendent truths that will
give our lives a meaning
not only that but we naturally recognize
our own sin our own guilt
and we look for ways of relieving
ourselves of that burden we seek
atonement we seek absolution
we seek penance
anti-racism provides an outlet for those
desires it's the wrong Outlet
it's wholly unsatisfying and
insufficient but it's the sort of
religion that non-religious secular
Liberals are stuck with this is all they
got
the religion has borrowed you know the
concept of it borrows a lot of the
concepts because it doesn't create
anything of its own
leftism never does so it can only borrow
from what already exists
in this case it borrows the concept of
original sin
from Christianity
and comes up with its own warped version
of course in Christian theology original
sin is guilt shared by all people
everywhere we are flawed we are a fallen
race you know and by race we mean the
human race
but the leftist anti-racist religion
preaches about a flawed and Fallen race
meaning specifically the white race
we white people are the carriers of
original sin
while the other races are Angelic
Guiltless uncorrupted beings
this is their mythology it's their
creation story
it's their religion
because we all need religion
and we will end up with one one way or
another
and so in some ways this person being
liberal lonely sad self-loathing and
also a woman she was destined to fall
into the anti-racism religion The
anti-racism Cult
was always going to end up this way
these days
and yet she is still today I must say in
spite of that canceled and that'll do it
for
this portion of the show is move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]